في خضم الصراع صراع النفوذ المتزايد بين
الصين والولايات المتحده ادلى قائد مشاه
البحريه في الجيش الامريكي بتصريح مثير
رجح فيه كفه الجيش الصيني على نظيره
الامريكي في حال نشوب اي حرب في المحيط
الهادئ اعتبر ديفيد برجر في التصريحات
التي ادلى بها لمجله نيوزويك ان قوات
بلاده تفتقر الى القدره على رضع اي صراع
مع الصين في المحيط الهادئ هذا واشاد قائد
مشات البحريه الامريكيه بالصين معتبرا
اياها المنافسه الوحيد القادر على الجمع
بين القوه الاقتصاديه والدبلوماسيه
والتكنولوجيه لتحدي النظام الدولي وبحسب
قائد مشاه البحريه الامريكيه فان الصين
باتت تتفوق بشكل واضح في صناعه السفن
والتي قامت باستعراضها مؤخرا خلال
المناورات العسكريه حول تايوان كما ان
الصين تبدو اكثر استعدادا لاي مواجهه
عسكريه بحريه من خلال اجراء عمليات اطلاق
الصواريخ من السفن اكثر من اي دوله اخرى
خارج مناطق الحرب الفعليه هذا واقر
المسؤول الامريكي بان هناك انخفاضا في
توافر السفن والمنصات البحريه في ظل
التركيز بشكل اكبر على اسلحه الجويه
والبريه وفضلا عن تراجع صناعه السفن نسبيا
في امريكا قياسا بالصين فان شرائها ايضا
عرفت توقفا مؤقتا